[Music]
we have not made progress in the
foundations of physics for about 40
years
and this problem is becoming more
pressing
year after year
physics is a very mature discipline
it's one of the oldest scientists that
there is and the simple things have been
done so um you
expect some kind of slowdown um for
example because it becomes more and more
difficult this is why we see larger and
larger experiments larger and larger
collaborations more and more expensive
experiments
but the main reason for the slowdown is
not this difficulty because we still
make these experiments
and
we still see a lot of theoretical
activity in these areas it's just that
it doesn't seem to be going anywhere
it's like people are running faster and
faster but they're running on a
treadmill not getting anywhere
what's really um at the core of the
problem is that physicists and
foundations of physics rely on beauty to
discover the next best fundamental law
they
think that the foundations of physics
the way that we currently have them as
as with general relativity and the
standard model are just not pretty
enough
these theories leave them wanting for
various reasons
for example in the standard model
we have three different types of
interactions
there is the electromagnetic interaction
that most of you will probably have
heard of
and then there is the strong and the
weak nuclear force
but these kind of sit next to each other
in a quite awkward way and it would be
much prettier if there were ultimately
all three aspects of one large
interaction that would be described by a
one symmetry group so this is what is
called a grand unified theory
and it's just aesthetically much more
appealing and this is why a lot of
physicists think that this is how nature
should work so i have this little image
here
which shows you a certain kind of
symmetry group which is called e8
you can think of these little dots
basically as being particles with a
certain properties a charge
color color charge spin and so on and
these lines as being the connections
between
the particles so this is one of the
possible
beautiful theories that
physicists are considering
in the foundations to make the standard
model
prettier problem is they invent these
prettier theories um and then they go
out and try to test them
usually by spending a lot of money
because as i just said these experiments
are not cheap and then they are
surprised if no evidence is found to
support them
it's even worse than that actually
because they also don't get the message
that this is a procedure which clearly
is working but they've been doing this
since the 1980s
part of the problem is that they are
largely unaware that this is what they
are doing because these requirements of
beauty have become mathematical
standards um so a lot of physicists will
actually be really really offended if
you tell them that they rely on beauty
because they don't know that that's what
they're doing
ultimately where these arguments come
from it's the reason why physicists
would want nature to be in this
particular way is because it would be
more beautiful
but metaphysical assumptions is exactly
what it is these are assumptions about
nature that themselves are not based on
evidence their beliefs basically
[Music]
you